it is fair to say a brand-new Democratic
field the better part of a year former
Vice President Joe Biden dominated the
polls and the other candidates in the
race attacked him from the left which is
weird to see Biden still believed in
law-enforcement and international
borders and he opposed forced busing
along with virtually every other
American so he was obviously one of
those right-wing extremist from the
Obama administration that's what they
were telling you on the debate stage it
was bizarre thankfully that line of
attack is over because Joe Biden's
presidential campaign itself is in
effect over nobody thinks Biden is going
to be the Democratic nominee Elizabeth
Warren is the front-runner now that's
not contested the race is now hers to
lose so during last night's debate her
rivals on the stage decide to help her
do just that lose watch your signature
senator is to have a plan for everything
except this at least Bernie's being
honest here and saying how he's gonna
pay for this and that taxes are gonna go
up and I'm sorry Elizabeth but you have
not said that I'm gonna say something
that is probably gonna offend some
people here but I'm the only one whose
stage has gotten anything really big
done and I appreciate Elizabeth's work
but again the difference between a plan
and a pipe dream is something that you
can actually get done I went on the
floor and got you votes
I got votes for that bill I convinced
people to vote for it I want to give a
reality check here to Elizabeth because
no one on this stage wants to protect
billionaires not even the billionaire
wants to protect billionaire sometimes I
think that Senator Warren is is more
focused on being punitive or or pitting
some part of the country against the
other
she's punitive when bado
or Roarke mr. armed federal agents
coming to your house calls you out for
divisive attacks it's time to pay
attention and in fact he does make a
fair point
the main reason Warren has surpassed a
Bernie Sanders in the hearts of primary
voters despite pretty close economic
programs is that she's the one farmer
willing to descend into the filth of
identity politics bernie is an ideologue
there are some things that he just won't
say Elizabeth Warren will say anything
just
minutes ago she tweeted this quote every
person deserves to be treated with
dignity and respect and that starts with
using correct pronouns
I'm Elizabeth my pronouns are she her
and hers in case you were wondering kiss
was any question at all that kind of
posturing is central to Elizabeth
Warren's campaign she's happy to tell
you and often does that you're worth
less or you're worth more based on how
you were born unfortunately that works
right now in the Democratic Party
one thing Elizabeth Warren is not
willing to say however is how much our
single-payer government health care plan
will cost trillions of dollars obviously
nobody disputes that nobody disputes
that and in fact as a mathematical
matter there is no way to raise that
kind of money without hiking taxes on
the middle class it's simple arithmetic
and yet for some reason one refuses to
admit that watch you have not specified
how you're going to pay for the most
expensive plan Medicare for all will you
raise taxes on the middle class for
paper to pay for it yes or no so I have
made clear what my principles are here
and that is costs will go up for the
wealthy and for big corporations and for
hardworking middle-class families costs
will go down Mayor Budaj you say senator
Warren has been quote evasive about how
she's gonna pay for Medicare for all
what's your response well we heard it
tonight a yes or no question that didn't
get a yes or no answer save that tape
there are a lot of moments in debates
that seem like a huge deal of the time
everyone's yapping about him but in the
end turn out to be completely
meaningless this is not one of those
moments health care is always at the top
of voters concerns and so our taxes for
that matter if Elizabeth Warren can't
even explain her own signature plan to
rearrange the entire American health
care system she can't win even the post
debate MSNBC panel acknowledged as much
I thought she seemed a little petulant
at times when she was being challenged
you think a little yes Bernie Sanders
says she just won't go there and she was
pummeled for it they attacked her and
she was uncomfortable she did not handle
it very well
so was it really that bad for Elizabeth
Warren last night
we'll see she definitely a better
treatment than Joe Biden you got
journalists don't like Joe Biden Biden
has zero allies in America's wolken
newsrooms worn by contrast has plenty of
allies pretending to be journalists for
example this morning and why you
journalism professor Jay Rosen the guy
whose name often pops up despite no
talent whatsoever demanded that
reporters stopped asking specific
questions about Warren's policies again
a journalism professor telling you not
to ask questions quote the make
Elizabeth Warren say she would raise
taxes in the middle class question
should be a credibility killer for the
journalists who keep asking it and quote
now amazingly Margaret Sullavan of the
Washington Post agreed with that she
wrote this journalists are kindly doing
president Trump's work for him when they
insist on trying to pin down senator
Elizabeth Warren declares she would
raise taxes to fund to Medicare for all
of course it's legitimate to dig into
the cost but not in a way that creates a
nice GOP campaign ad you listen to that
to journalists telling you if the answer
hurts Democrats don't ask the question
don't tell your readers or viewers what
the truth is if it increases the chances
that Donald Trump could get reelected is
that journalism no it's pure propaganda
it is the definition of propaganda you
che Rosen journalism professor telling
journalists not to ask questions
unbelievable